i've been tasked to design a dowel house
for drew barrymore
[Music]
now don't be fooled this may be a
miniature home but i'm going to give you
some large tips and tricks that you can
actually apply at home
i basically see the living room is kind
of like the vibe capital of the home
honestly you can't have a home without a
living room i mean think about it it
would kind of be like having charlie's
angels without charlie i mean you can't
have charlie's angels like charlie but i
digress let's get started you know as i
get up every morning and sip on my
little coffee i got to thinking what is
the vibe that i want for this space so
drew is a girl who likes color but not
necessarily bright color she's more of a
softer hue type of girl so she likes her
sage greens she likes her you know nubby
oatmeals and so i wanted to bring that
element into the space for the walls i
wanted to go with an interesting pattern
you know i didn't want to do wallpaper
so i knew the most cost effective way to
create a design was to use board and
batten so board and batten is a
technique where you use
several layers of wood and then you kind
of frame them out until they make a nice
design so we created a chair rail
version of that that went a little bit
higher than typically that way you can
place artwork above it i wanted the
floor to have some
character you know there are so many
different options that you can choose
when you're looking at flooring but i
found that a chevron design is now more
of a modern classic that's timeless but
it gives the room a little bit of an
edge
okay people here is one common mistake
that i'm so sick and tired of hearing
and seeing that is the use of the five
six seven piece furniture set you don't
need all those pieces you're smarter
than that you're braver than that you
can do it so what i typically try to do
is start off with one key piece whatever
that happens to be like whether it's
your grandmother's coffee table that's
been passed down try to stick with that
one piece let's say you found like the
perfect coffee table but it's in the
color that you don't want it in well you
can easily strip this piece sand paint
it down and then spray paint it again to
the color of your dreams and you get
exactly what you want the same thing
with furniture i'll find an inexpensive
piece maybe on like facebook marketplace
i love the chair but i would prefer to
reupholster the fabric and have it taken
to be reupholstered
so i started off with a nice natural
upholster sofa and then i flanked the
sofa with two rattan chairs which are
really popular right now the other thing
that i found was a glass coffee table
that had a wooden top that ironically
also had a chevron design which would
tie into the floor drew is also into
like picking and pairing things from the
80s a little bit so the rattan chairs
that i found for the space i knew we're
just going to be like 100
drew as a matter of fact when she sees
this speech she's probably going to try
to see how she can blow them up and make
them like regular size so they can fit
into her own home the other thing that i
wanted to do was to flank the walls with
some type of larger cabinetry so i found
a beautiful vintage like piece that has
about 20 drawers where drew can put all
of her knickknacks and whatnots and then
i wanted to kind of finish things off
with two things that you cannot leave in
a space you need a rug just to ground
everything i went with a jute rug just
because jute rugs are very durable
they're family friendly you can run
across it and they really won't get
messed up and then i finished everything
off with a beautiful chandelier just
kept it matte black and simple something
that's transitional and you can use it
for
dollhouse to dollhouse to come
i'm feeling really good about the design
of the living room i think i can take a
little tea break but before i do that i
want to check in with my friend matthew
and see how he's doing
okay drew we got your clothes
let's hope everything fits
all right these shoes are custom made so
we'll see
perfect
okay let's try the clothes
these fit i guess we'll
see what we can do
these uh
look a little small
all right drew you want to come for a
fitting
[Music]
we've got charlie for the angels i feel
like everything is all set and we can
now move on to another portion of the
house
i mean this is cute and all but like can
i please get like a real cup of coffee
because i've had like 50 of these little
guys ah human-sized coffee
just get yourself
[Music]